why are you guys saying this cap when a
woman says
that is this on one hand
is that not a real thing anymore
um it was just because there's not many
virgins around me
because men always think that women are
lying about their body count i don't
understand
why why would we be lying about our body
camera
can you say that again sorry
women lie about their body camp because
they don't want to reveal their true
nature
really yeah so if
a woman's a [ __ ] hoe she's going to
keep that
literally hidden she doesn't want nobody
to know that she's a whole the streets
are talking the streets do you think do
you think you can tell though like like
because example if i meet a girl in a
club i'm i'm more like and they're like
they seem like that type of person but
if i meet a girl in the library who's
never been to a club before i'm gonna
probably believe her body count over
someone who like dude like you can kind
of tell i'm not saying in general but
the the way girls act if they're
confident bubbly stuff like that like
you you what are you what do you guys
think because i i think girls know more
behind the scenes than guys do like we
hear more we know more do you think guys
can tell
no no
no they think they do they can't tell
because they're already saying kaplan is
already wrong
same way they can't tell when their
girls cheating the same way they can't
tell
[Laughter]
is it was there someone you know
that that happened with what happened i
want to be in the know you're laughing
i'm just saying there's a lot of girls
out there that move mad they have men at
home
they're the men don't know
they don't know do you think that
they're cheating because they married or
in a relationship with their second
choice and it wasn't who they really
wanted i feel like um when it comes to
relationships people um
lose that drive when the years like
start to pile up people stop being like
as affectionate as romantic like going
that extra mile i think that's what
drives people apart and maybe that's
when one person might step out you think
women get bored
and then she
i feel like if you get bored then you
haven't picked the right person
or maybe it could be attention like
you're like the person someone else is
giving you more attention than your
partner which you don't know that could
be but why are you turning your your eye
in the first place because something is
happening yeah yeah but it's tiring like
i'm not gonna lie like even like i'm
married and happily married but like
it's tiring just like my wife puts on
makeup or puts on a dress and if i don't
say anything like anything at all
then that's it a mood's ruined right so
it's like i have to comment because
they've made an effort but to me it's
like i don't care but is it maybe
because you didn't compliment her enough
when you guys were dating or but that
that's what i mean like it's like and
guys just don't express it as much maybe
that i'm thinking it in my head but i'm
not gonna say it like it's just but
you're quick to go unlike someone like a
girl's picture on instagram i mean i
don't do that so i can't speak for all
guys
but i don't do that because i i just
find that i find that action a bit weird
like going on instagram looking at other
girls and then liking them or like say
if like a lot of guys these days watch a
lot of twitch streamers like the female
twitch streamers yeah and i feel like if
you had a partner that is a lit to me a
little bit weird if you had a partner
like well it depends why you're watching
twitch stream of course but for me i it
just feels a little icky
well i think like women
they are very difficult to satisfy which
is why
um what was it body count you said body
cam
which is why that's so important so that
they can connect to their husband
um
yeah i think that's it and i also
understand your point when you were
saying how they were sleeping with guys
that are like tens and nines when
they're like not
because it just like
they want that but they can't attain it
yeah and that's why i think like a lot
of girls think they're settling but it's
just their level your level's what you
can get to commit to you
otherwise it's out of your life before
yeah i mean
guys levels who they can get to sleep
with them girls level is who they can
get to commit to them
if you can't get him to commit if you
just want to be with you that's not your
level
just to add on that right you said
something me yeah you you said
you said ah when and par corrected you
said date
when we were talking about guys sleeping
with them and it was the idea that most
girls have it in their minds that the
tens that they're [ __ ] let's say if
there are six
they're actually dating them
but in fact you're actually just
sleeping with them
and so most girls have it like oh i'm
dating that guy
but really you're not
and that's the delusion that we're
trying to point out that a lot of women
who are [ __ ] the tens who are
actually sixes
are not understanding that that's not
their level because they think they're
dating them but really they're just
sleeping with them yeah because i would
also say those guys at the top level if
you're a high value man or whatever you
want to call it
they have more choice so like you're not
the only pretty girl going for them
right so then they actually are looking
for other things because they have a ton
of pretty girls going for him and
whereas the girl probably thinks in that
situation oh i'm a catch i i got i got
this guy stuff like that but but i from
my experience
the the people who who are high earners
they if they do get a lot of girls
anyway they're actually more picky
on who they who they want so why do so
many like ugly guys have such a high
body count if that's the case
but it's not true is it because they
don't have money
money no they're not actually ugly
that's the thing
you you think they're ugly because women
find 80 of men unattractive
but it's the same with like ugly girls
as well like how how i come it's so easy
for them to get the guy that's the 10.
well yeah
it depends there's a couple dynamics
that i see if the guys attend like
usually she has other qualities
oh is he dating her sleeping with her no
just sleeping together oh well guys will
sleep with anything the [ __ ] we should
just get in bed and yeah guys guys will
sleep with girls they would never be
seen in public with ever yeah and you
see people cheat with uglier girls like
they might have a banging one why does
that happen yeah yeah you got you gotta
worry about the ugly girls too you got
to worry oh that's your baby mom
explain it no it's men men are looking
to qualify where women are looking to
disqualify so like if you're going on a
date with a guy you're thinking like i
have these requirements and let me see
if he meets them where men are like oh
is she hot enough good enough
is she is she nice enough oh that's
maybe not nice enough to date but
tonight that's yeah good enough
because men men swipe right on dating
apps around 50 of the time so they find
roughly 50 of women attractive where
women only find five to maybe 20 on the
high end percent of guys attractive
wow
so
yeah yeah and the guys you know you said
ugly guys aren't but the thing is ugly
guys just aren't getting anything at all
those are the people you're even
acknowledging the people that you're
even talking to there's a lot of guys
that just at home all day that they just
like do whatever they're doing that that
you don't even see so so it's in your
circle of guys that you're like oh this
guy's ugly but it's even people but then
that's why one in three are what would
you say one and three are like virgins
or something like that but someone might
find them attractive just because
they're ugly to somebody
and on top of that maybe you're right
you said that they're sitting at home
that's probably why they're not they're
not [ __ ] because no one can see them
they're not visible to the world
but then if someone if someone if
someone found them attractive they'd be
[ __ ]
yeah but if they're sitting at home all
day then they're not going to be they're
not going to but they might have co it
might be confidence as well women want a
confident man if you're not approaching
me and that that could be you could not
be confident enough which is why you're
not able to get to that level you could
be next to a girl maybe you're not
confident enough to put it on her and
start something okay imagine if you went
up to 50 guys and hit on him and all of
them said no
would you be confident
yeah that would be like yeah and that's
and the thing is like even even when i
when i went to that pickup artist boot
camp i i understood like men on a
different level because they'd be decent
looking guys and the amount of rejection
they would have to go through to find
one girl that would be even remotely
interested and this was at a bar where
they're drunk where the odds are in
their favor was like crazy to me
like guys have to go through so much
rejection to get laid that
that honestly if they get enough
rejection i can understand why they just
want to stop trying
yeah i mean i would i would back up your
point a tiny bit because um
uh one of my exes i let her leave her
profile open because i found it
interesting reading what messages guys
like you know would send and some of
like
50 or 50 percent of them are just like
creepy or like seriously creepy or weird
or just you know a d-pick or whatever
like out of nowhere so i'll give you
that for for that bit but yeah like
pearl said with the other the other half
okay next question
do you guys think people deserve love
everyone deserves love absolutely not